all right Liz yes Liz where'd you grow
up where are you from originally born
and raised in L.A and tell me about your
family I have both my parents and I have
one older brother
my parents emigrated from Korea it was
like a pretty rough upbringing because
they're just like so like conservatively
Korean and
um so that was like the reason why there
was so much abuse in the home and um
for you as a child yes yeah
um
yeah like it what was like kind of [ __ ]
sorry
um like screwed up was like
like whenever they would like abuse me
and my brother right after that they
would be like oh we're doing it because
we love you
so I just had like this twisted
like intro like
I don't know like it was just
I remember love being such a weird
concept to me and I remember early I was
like in kindergarten
um I was just in the playground playing
with everyone and um I was going on
pinching kids until they cried because I
genuinely thought I was like sprinkling
love around oh no but it's yeah it
sounds
like you're the love you received was
conditional
yeah very conditional like was there
expectation to get good grades or oh
yeah
um grades was such a huge thing like
school I mean I'm happy that my mom was
so involved in my academics
but it was like even if I brought home
straight A's all the time it was never
enough
um so I was I don't know I never felt
like I was good enough
and I'm still like struggling with that
today
you carry that for the rest of your life
[Music]
and then you've went on to become a
school teacher yeah yeah
um that also ties into my childhood
because like the first day I started
school in kindergarten um I realized
like oh my gosh there are adults and
other people who don't want to hit me or
like don't want to neglect me so school
was the first place I felt physically
and emotionally safe
so that was the kind of environment I
wanted to write for others so
each right now that's what you're doing
now hopefully what grade are you
teaching I teach 9 through 12.
so you're a high school teacher yeah
what do you teach English English
in what neighborhood in Watts
yeah you're in the hood right right
um and a lot of people have like this
opinion that like these Watts kids like
these Watts kids are just troublemakers
and that like every day in the classroom
is hell but it's not like that
whatsoever really yeah I mean granted
like I'm guilty as well like I went into
I'm working there like kind of like
timid and afraid but no these like we
have so much some of like the most
hard-working and genuine and just
because they've been through so much you
know it's great to hear yeah there's
they're great I love them is it a
racially diverse
student body or no no not quite they're
mostly Latinos
so you're in a neighborhood that's
mostly Latinos do you think of wasps as
being mostly mostly African-American
right yeah but your school is is mostly
the channels
but they're
they're not joining gangs and all that
kind of stuff like the reputation we do
have some students who are like
Affiliated but when we're in school like
they just leave that at the door we're
just we're so loving and respectful
towards each other it's a really good
Community that's great it's so nice to
hear how long have you been doing it at
this school it's gonna be my third year
I've been teaching probably for like 10
years oh yeah
what is your
opinion on the future
Generations
we're producing
um I feel like this generation of like
young people that we have they have such
a strong voice and they advocate for
what they believe is right and I think
that's something that we need for the
future and I tell my students all the
time like being an English teacher I
want them to use their voice I want them
to like use their writing to get their
needs met and like spread whatever
important message that they have and I
believe that
I hope there will be positive changes do
you see kids that are just slipping
through the cracks because of their life
at home with their families I do
um
some of our students are homeless
um and it's like the home life is very
like toxic for them so
um like our school is kind of the only
safe haven for them but at the same time
they have their own things going on so
um attendance is pretty sparse and when
we see students just missing so many
days
um it's really disheartening for us and
then they just drop out and you don't
see them again
but we do what we can with the ones who
show up are there a lot of kids who drop
out
um we have a handful every year but then
like our school is very small and we
have less than 100 students
um but it's a very small school yeah and
I think that's why I love it so much but
it's a public school yes it is
and you do you have kids I don't and
you're married you're single single yeah
what is your opinion on life in LA
as a single woman
oh my gosh
I
mean
you know the thing is like I don't even
like stop to think about that you know I
don't think anyone's even asked for that
but um my life has just been all about
work
and
so I don't know it's weird to stop and
think like what is life like to be me
um I just try to keep myself busy all
the time I'm not really interested in
the whole marriage and kids thing anyway
you know no I never really was and I
think I'm gonna screw up my kids if I
have them I'm like too much of a
perfectionist that they're gonna feel it
and they're going to grow up like super
anxious just like me and we don't need
that
do you think the Asian community
the parents that raised your generation
are too strict I mean that's the
reputation they have
yeah they're extremely strict and
um for them it's all about like how they
look to the public eye so whatever I do
I mean they probably the parents
probably met well
meant well yeah they they mean well but
their their way of doing it is probably
not helping yeah yeah I'm sure they did
the best that they could but it doesn't
mean it was right you know
um
I have like so much anxiety now because
like everything just has to be like
perfect and
um I just feel like this impending doom
all the time
do you have friends um all the friends
that I meet it's not really friends you
know I don't reach out to them when I
need to it's I go to the bar for that
we just talk to people there and then
they become acquaintances I guess and
back to your students do you see that
job where you're trying to educate these
kids get to you emotionally it does very
much so every other week There's a story
about a student whose friend or family
member died from gang violence and so
many other kids like they can't access
like Medical Care they have such poor
like living situation but seeing them
like put in so much effort and just into
the academics because they know that
that's their way to get out it's just so
fulfilling for me
um this past year actually I've had a
couple students that completely made my
teaching career they were like oh Liz
you know how some students say like a
teacher made a difference in their lives
well for me that's you and
um it's nice to hear yeah and even
though there are like tough days in the
classroom moments like that really make
everything worth it and like I learned
from them every day I become like a
better person every day for my kids it
sounds like meaningful work for you it
is I can't imagine myself doing anything
else are you compensated financially in
an adequate way no
no teach yourself for the money right no
um I mean but then again like I have
everything I need you know I have my own
place I have two cats
um I can feed myself
teachers cops and firemen should
probably all be compensated financially
much more than they are right yeah
yeah I agree but I don't know if this is
just me thinking but if we like teachers
did get paid more
is the morale gonna decrease
you know like I feel like
if I cared so much about money I
wouldn't be a teacher and then if
teachers got paid more
maybe people would just become teachers
just for the money it's hard it's hard
to strike that balance yeah
I mean I do it just because I love it
the paycheck's nothing to me it's the
best reason to do something
do you have any regrets in your life do
you wish you had done something
differently
it sounds like you love your work I love
my work so much I mean I love where I am
right now and
but living in La which is such a
you know La is a reputation as being
very shallow and it's like it's all
about just money and image and all that
and you're doing something that means it
means a lot to you and you're probably
paid very little for it yet you're happy
yeah I am that's refreshing to hear yeah
I'm very happy
[Music]
it's like weird for me to even say that
because like
when I think about it like am I happy or
am I just is or is happiness just like
an absence of
like pain
you know um
I mean like I have my own like mental
illnesses but I think at this moment I
am happy but what issues do you struggle
with mentally
um well so I have depression anxiety I
have eating disorders
yeah and I self-harm really
does that stem from your upbringing with
your parents
um yes
like we weren't allowed to really talk
about our emotions that's very taboo in
the Korean culture or Asian
um and for me specifically I'm a brother
like we weren't allowed to yell but we
were angry we weren't allowed to cry
when we were sad
and so like
the eating disorder thing it's funny
well it's not funny but like for me the
reason why evenings were like stuck with
me was because that was the only thing I
could undo like the pain that I
experienced the trauma I can't undo that
but the amount of food I put in my
system and how much I you know expelled
from my system I could like literally
control that it's about control yeah
yeah
um and it's not it's not about bodies or
weight like so many people think it's
not about that at all it just exhibits
itself that way but you know it's about
it's about control it's about just
coping mechanism do you find when you
are
fulfilled and happy that those
issues don't rear their heads as often
or as much yeah definitely there's more
to do with just being happy
being fulfilled
I
it does help me
like it's just it does distract me from
the urges
um
but are you still there yes
yes very loudly I mean I've had an
English word since I was 13. I'm 33 now
so yeah
what's your biggest fear now
what do you worry about
um
it used to be disappointing my parents
but this might sound so stupid but I'm
afraid of like what if I die it's gonna
take care of my cats that sounds like
such an LA shallow answer oh God
um you love your cats I love my cats no
I think I'm afraid of like
just to like not be shallow about it um
like the world
continuing or like just the world being
ignorant or like a large population of
the world just being like just hating
people who are different and like that's
somewhere that I would never want future
generations to live in
um I just hate the idea that we're still
here right now like
having these protests that should have
it should be like a non-issue so that
continuing is a pretty big fear I don't
know if it's a worldwide thing or an
American thing but it seems like hate
and judgment and racism are all
alive and well yeah they're strong and
people will not let go of them I think I
think hates an addiction
yeah for a lot of people
yeah we just love to do it I mean
whether it's hating the other political
party or hating
their neighbor or hating
another race or
somebody on social media or whatever
there just it seems to be
their preoccupation that they cannot put
down right it's so sad and it makes me
curious like why because it takes effort
to be hateful oh yeah it's draining yeah
and like we're supposed to accept each
other and like I just I'm just so
curious like fascinated about like where
does this come from what does this mean
to hurt come from well I think it's when
you're miserable with yourself you
you're projecting it onto somebody else
and you find ways to do that yeah you
find somebody who makes you who triggers
you and you'll
Target them
for whatever reason yeah it's sad
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
my gosh my kids ask me this
um it's do your best and your best is
enough
um I when I was in a treatment center
this was like back in 2011 my favorite
counselor there told me like I was
freaking out for some reason she was
like Liz just do your best and your best
is enough and that was just like
earth-shattering to me and
um like no one has ever said that to me
before so that's what I would say I mean
a lot of my students are like afraid of
making mistakes or so like they don't
even try and like not just students but
like we all have that to like some level
and
um just do your best you're not you're
not not enough you're not too much
you're perfect
have you been in love before
I have
have I I think so yeah well you're in
your Prime you know
being a single female and then in terms
of having a child you're you're at that
age where if you're going to do it now
would be the time to do it
right do you find yourself lonely or
frustrated or no no I don't find myself
lonely refreshed at all
um I
I mean I'm happy not having kids out
be happy if I were single for the rest
of my life you know um
I've had this like this like fantasy
since I was little like I just want to
get a Winnebago and just go you know
like that's my home and I just meet
like people along the way but it's
frustrating for me to you know hear
somebody who's sensible and educated and
seems to have their head in the right
place not wanting to have children while
there's people that are that are as
Reckless
as you can imagine as I interview and
there's having kids over and over again
and then abandoning them right that's
hard to watch it is it's tragic
um
there should be a you should have a
license to have
to produce I think I agree
can you need a license to drive you need
a license to cut hair but you don't need
a license to have seven kids raise a
human being
and it's wild but no I don't feel lonely
I'm I can honestly say I'm content but
situation and you and you like living in
Los Angeles
I do
I I do um I haven't really lived
anywhere else for enough of a Time
but I I love it here and it's easy to
get places and like
I just like the schools here because
they're I don't like the edge like the
um the district
but that's the reason why I want to stay
here
what is the biggest problem you see in
the
body of students that you are educating
right now with my students yeah like
this like what do you see like are the
are the dads present in their lives are
they
a lot of them
um come from a single family home
um
but I I would say drugs
would be the biggest issue drugs are an
issue in your in your class
yeah
yeah and like some of them
um you know we have staff members who
are like really supportive so they open
up to the staff and we are able to help
some of them but others they just kind
of
fall through the cracks and um
yeah
I wish there was more that I could do to
help but
I mean I was doing drugs at that age so
you were oh yeah
13 was a very eventful age for me that's
what I tell people it's when everything
started so you understand these kids
um I do and I feel like like that I'm
I feel fortunate to be able to connect
with them on that unique level because I
have experienced it yeah sometimes a
child will have a more meaningful bond
with a teacher
than they will with their own parents or
anyone else
yeah absolutely I know that was
definitely the case for me a teacher who
gets them
and just listens and accepts them like
unconditionally yeah it's so important
all right Liz thank you so much for
sharing your story you're welcome thank
you hope you have a great school year
next semester thank you